hello I'm Mike Moser from University of
Zurich and my talk is about solving
real-world business problem in the
classroom hello everybody since this is
one of the last talks I'm very happy to
see you here yeah i'm going to tell you
what i have done the last three or four
month solving real-world business
problems in the classroom based
classroom it was a seminar at university
of zurich for master students in
business administration and yeah so i
wanted to do something really authentic
something really applied just real word
so no textbooks no textbook problems no
toy problems so everything was real and
so the cases the students had to solve
we're submitted by companies and then
was actually a challenge so we did this
for the first time so I went and asked
some companies to submit actual problems
they have and I promised them to come up
with really innovative solutions and
yeah so that where there was a high risk
for me and on the other hand for
students it was also something like yeah
not what they see at universities every
day so it was really challenging
and yeah so I asked them to solve all
the cases using Mathematica bow from
technologies and yeah so of course they
have no not so much experience with
programming because I have business
administration students so they usually
only care about making money and so yeah
so it was it was quite a challenge and
yeah so I I don't want to spend too much
time on this so let's go and see the
results is it so it's here you can see
actually that's a web page so the thing
is I both thinking how should we deploy
our results our presentations to the
companies and I mean handing out
Mathematica notebooks is it's not the
most convenient way to do this and so I
that yeah we have this great progress in
technology so I will try to do it like
really state-of-the-art and like a
webpage and so this is it um you see
here's a small welcome section so here
our cooperation partners so you can see
oh it's like yeah the resolution is not
optimal but yeah you can see there
there's some like the big players in the
industry like Deloitte or Ernst & Young
and we also had like some some start ups
from Switzerland and also
nonprofit organizations WWF and from the
from the technology side to be be used
only for from technologies and a cloud
based in Switzerland called safe Swiss
cloud and like the web technology but
what do you see here like the HTML and
CSS stuff but yeah so that's it and yeah
the idea was to support all devices the
the company representatives will just
use their tablet or notebook and can see
the results from the seminar the
presentation immediately once they have
one of the supported browsers okay so
let's let's see we had like six projects
and I will just go over them so this
first is predicting real estate demand
it's from a start-up from Zurich and
what they are doing is they they buy all
the data from from search subscriptions
on portals like emo Scout or yeah like
all the data for Switzerland which is
quite interesting because you can do a
lot of estimation and stuff like this
with the data and the basic question
just to give you an idea is you own an
apartment in burn or Zurich and you want
to know how how should you price it so
also rent you can expect and or if you
want to buy your house
sell your house or stuff like this so
good let's go into the presentation so
again all what you see here is on the
web and yeah so I have to apologize saw
the the the beam irresolute maybe I can
change it because it's just not can can
be put it higher the Beamer resolution
or wouldn't work okay okay so yes so um
this is a presentation of the the
project it contains a video from this
start up and just some slides and yeah
so what they basically did Oh looks
really sorry just give me a second i'll
try to to change this it was ok when i
tested it think
okay so no no it's much better um okay
so what what I did they analyze all the
data from the from the search
subscriptions which are 350,000 date per
week and then they they like look for
the patterns what were what people
willing to sell for for specific
combination of space and attractivity
and region and they came up with a great
idea I think to do a pricing tool based
on the data set and yeah at this point I
would have liked to to embed the tool I
become later to why we can't see it here
but they they actually really
implemented a great solution and we're
quite accurate so they they were able to
estimate the the rent for for random
apartment in Zurich up to a hundred
francs precision which is really really
good so that there was a really
interesting project and there's there's
one more aspect yeah yeah the day they
used basically at the beginning we used
the data sets and and some machine
learning approaches because it's it's
quite difficult with the data maybe you
you did that search subscription thing
so usually the users would not fill in
all the information so you just feelin
like I'm looking for three
and up to 100 square meters or something
like this and so the first challenge is
to fill out the gaps and so this is what
they did using a machine learning
approach yeah yeah he you can see
actually the data set and it's just too
much white space to to do something with
it so yeah what they did they thought
about what can we predict welcome how
can we use machine learning and tried
all the methods implemented and then
compared like tested them and compared
it to the to the real distributions and
yeah that that is like really really a
great project in my view because the
three students did they they had no
experience with mathematical programming
so they had like three months to do this
and now the company told us they want to
implement this and yeah they asked me
how they can use Mathematica in their
company and where they can buy it so it
would have also really like a success
story yeah but I want to go to other
cases well so this is a district
classical business case cutting
procurement costs the question is your
big company and you want to cut costs by
twenty percent how would you do this
yeah here again some ideas and I cannot
tell the whole story so they basically
came up with a with a with a business
modeling approach because it's it's very
it's you have like a billion
ways to cut costs to find a pro to do
this and they model this and at the end
yeah they calculated the cost and they
did like a tool which is here but
unfortunately only a screenshot we come
later to this good so let's go to
another case understanding mobile
payment behavior this is another startup
from Zurich they programmed an app where
you can transfer money from yeah just
friend to friend or you can also pay
with it and in the supermarket or
whatever you want and they don't have
users or that much users at the moment
so they they are just in the inner like
prototype or start stadium so they they
were really interested in what what
matters in order to to yeah to attract
users and what the users are actually
doing with with this app so what what
are they paying for and so what they did
then was yes some kind of unless so
here's he's a network so here they they
plotted the network of all transactions
and to see how people are connected
within the app network and identifying
the most active users and how they
yeah compared to others and here is what
they use the app for to pay for and it's
coffee and beer and lunch so yeah and
for this this this startup it these
insights were really really important
because they don't have the time to
think about all this doing all the
analyze steps and so I asked them
afterwards will this have an impact on
your future like business strategy and
then the guy said yeah people we will
use the results from tomorrow so that
there was also quite interesting and
they they asked us to to build a
reporting tool where you have like a
stream of data coming in and and you
would get like monitor of activities and
and and stuff so there was also very
interesting project here is another
project from established company why and
it was about covering out so large
company has factories in lots of
countries and now they they want to sell
parts of their production and so you
have to do evaluation for this so it's
it's very it goes into very much into
accounting but the problem is you have a
really really big data set of
transactions like really millions of
transactions and and they are not
consistent because you have like 10
different standards in
different legal structures in different
countries so if you want to do this this
valuation you have to like think about
how you can come up with a consistent
value and this was technically really
challenging they provided us with a XS
database with literally billions of
tables and connections and then at the
end the students came up with four
different approaches how to make data
consistent and and calculate the impact
and I see I think yeah here is small
animation to show like based on on the
parameter of accuracy how the approaches
will change and so I I don't want to go
into much detail but yeah so that's all
what was very interesting for me in this
project was the the manager from ey and
then asked students so how long did it
take you to to calculate this and there
I was thinking oh let's see how we can
compare and the students a like 30
minutes and and then the day right and
oh that's that's quite good so it takes
us like bomb at least 30 minutes so and
I looked at the code and of course it's
it's not optimized because students
which started coding like four months
ago and I think that states quite good
performance and for a next round I want
you to put it even further say like 10
minutes or something like this so um
yeah and and that's
it's quite a quite a good yeah chance to
really impress established companies
what you can do because they usually use
all the Microsoft Technology and don't
think even think about changing this
okay so ya see okay so one more thing
WWF you know it's a non-profit company
and totally depends on donations and
they have over two million followers on
facebook and the question is what kind
of impact has a post on facebook on the
donations at the end so how can they
optimize this and the solution from the
from the group was a tool where where
WWF can can insert their post and it
would estimate the likes and would give
you some recommendations on how you can
how you can improve it but again this is
only a screenshot because it didn't work
at the end in the cloud I will I will
show you the tools in a minute and last
but not least the case from the
Netherlands restructuring a retail
business to big companies in travel
agencies in the Netherlands merged and
now they wanted to know how they should
allocate their shops and yeah what I
want to mention is that all the
presentations you've seen now also have
a report motors so it's like the same
and you just you can enter it with one
click
but here you see a full text version
because with that we thought that not
everyone is following the presentation
or you want to make it available to
other people from from the company's
later so you you always get a full
report okay so since we're a little bit
short of time yeah but we'll take away
some really great feedback from the
companies we have lots of follow-up
project so some of the companies as the
air can can we get some some of your
students to fly to amsterdam and help of
and yes some some wanted to implement
the prototypes from the from the semi
now so that that was quite successful
and the students at least at the end
also like the results but the effort was
was quite high so okay so just to show
you how did we came to this point and
this is the course materials as I said
we were using the Wolfram language for
everything and here is how we did this
and I saw that there was the first case
showed you so importing the data using
semantic import so it was really really
hard coding and we used what we try to
use the most recent features like
classify wrote our own interpreter
functions and so on so we really try to
push to limit and yeah there were some
some issues with a version updates of
Mathematica and then the notation
changed a little bit and things like
this so but at the end the the Wolfram
language
to do the analyzers did really really
great job so you can do all the stuff
like Network analyze so you can write
complex algorithms process big data and
and so on so that there was really
powerful but come back to this but yeah
for for the students the it's really
hard to get started Eddie at the
beginning it's very frustrating because
nothing works they are not yeah almost
no opportunities to to get support there
they're not like a community like for
for matlab or are and so at the
beginning yeah they were a little bit
frustrated and with this seminar concept
that there was nothing predefined so
when when I started this seminar I had
no lecture materials and there was no
homepage there was nothing so all that
was developed like on the run so and
yeah so the day I tried things like live
coding in the lectures and yeah so that
there was not always successful because
yeah it's their business students so
maybe that was a little bit too hard for
the for the first time but yeah so now
let's go to the tools just to this just
to show you yet this this was the the
tool from the from the Deloitte case the
cutting the cost case a really simple
thing everything was was pre-calculated
but as you can see here it has quite a
lot of control so it's just a list and
then you click here and and you see how
much you
would cast a cut the cost using some
cost positions and it turned out that
with with the the number of controls
this was a really really expensive thing
so I asked the students or fed them yeah
just just try it with your war from
cloud account with your test account and
it turned out that this the students
said yeah after after two hours I went
out of cloud credits just just doing
this and I mean that's it's not this is
not rocket science so this is just just
a like yeah a little-little tool so here
is the WWF to show you this so this is
this really cool you can just paste the
post here world um and let's see
and then you can say ah i will post this
in june on the wednesday in the evening
and yeah you can see so it will it will
predict the likes shares comments and so
on and now then you can ask i want to
increase oh that's not working because
my Mathematica version crashed I can
reevaluate this and Mike I'm sorry to
interrupt but we need to move on to quiz
the experts in the next room okay I
think they've started to more minute two
more minutes okay yep so they the
students came up with really interesting
tools and this is what what the
companies like the most but at the end
we weren't able to deploy a single one
in the cloud somewhere like possible to
deploy but they were just not robust so
I deployed them and then ten minutes
later they were timed out or it was just
not not robust and so at the end I
decided no let's let's not included in
the presentations and just a quick view
on how we on how we did this we had a
cloud a classroom cloud with all the
course materials you can see here are
all the students from the course and I
could assignment groups and this is
actually how they did a slide so they
uploaded the pictures and then
here they they they made the slides just
enter the text and and the text for the
reports so the idea was I don't want to
ask my students to learn HTML and all
the other stuff so we give them an
editor to do this and yeah so my resume
of all this is the seminal concept was
quite successful in terms of satisfying
the companies and now that I have heard
about the recent development of the
cloud i'm looking forward that next year
we will have all the dynamic and
interactive features also on the web and
yeah i think that's that's quite
interesting concert and what's really
fun for me to to try all the new
technology